(upbeat music)
- [Katia] Being a twin, you're
always identified as a unit.
- [Jasmine] We've experienced
every moment in life together.
- [Katia] We learned to drive together,
you go to school together,
you're in the same class.
- [Jasmine] We went through the
same hardships as teenagers.
- [Katia] We work together, we're
on the phone together a lot.
- [Jasmine] You feel a connection
that you just don't with anybody else.
We've been together since day one.
- [Katia] It's been important for us,
as individuals, to forge our own paths.
Living far apart is
tough, but I always know
she has my back 100 percent.
- [Jasmine] I live in Index, Washington
at the base of the Cascade Mountains.
Everyday, I know it sounds
cliche, but I just wake up
feeling totally blessed. It's beautiful.
Usually in the morning, I
drink my coffee, I walk my dog
and a little bit before 9,
I call Katia, or she calls me.
I'm a paralegal, I'm kind of
the assistant for the attorney.
All-in-all, it's amazing
having my sister as the boss.
We're very close and, obviously,
very candid with each other,
but we're a team - working
together in a sense,
but different places.
- [Katia] I'm an immigration
attorney in New York.
It's obviously a fast-paced life,
but I do really love New Yorkers.
I love the vibrant
diversity that the City has.
It’s truly unique in the world,
of all the places I've ever been.
Starting my own practice, it's
long hours, it's high stress.
So I really appreciate the
work that Jasmine does.
- I definitely encourage her everyday.
You know, the bad days I'm like, "Let's
get off and take a ride."
- Jas and I have never
really been competitive,
but on the bike it's a different story.
We're very competitive on the bike.
- Katia is faster on the bike, hands down.
- I would win in a race.
- I would say Katia's
more competitive than me.
- I'm a nice sister.
- I would say I'm better at snowboarding.
I think she would agree with that.
- Me.
- I run marathons, and so running
was always my physical outlet.
But, the bike has really been a game-changer.
For one, you never really know
when you're gonna have
that space in your day.
And so, if I have a
break, maybe, in meetings,
I can take that opportunity
and really seize it.
- I'll see a class that
we wanna do and I'll say,
"Hey, are you down to do Alex's 5:30?,
“FYI - 8:30 your time."
I live in a super-small
town, about 600 people.
It's pretty cool to
hop on the Peloton bike
and, all of a sudden, I'm riding with
thousands of people from around the world.
- [Katia] I will filter the
leaderboard to just her and I.
- I'm usually hot out of the get-go.
- Jasmine can be leading
almost the entire ride.
Except for the end, I usually
have more steam than she does.
Jasmine has never made
a better time than me.
- Having this physical
outlet is really cool.
It's been another tool
for us to stay connected
and to see one another despite the distance.
- [Katia] Jas and I have matching tattoos,
they're identical.
- [Jasmine] It makes me think
of her every time I see it.
- [Katia] And I like to keep it
as a reminder of where I'm from.
- [Jasmine] It just reminds us of home.
Which is here and, I
guess, just being together.